I don't want any spoilers but I've so
loved the show and for anyone who
doesn't know it's about it starts the
show starts with some people who really
believe they're the last people on earth
and the crazy things they do yeah no one
else is living on earth anymore but all
the stuff is there we just saw the white
houses there and they they have all
these adventures it's really fun what's
what can we expect this season well as
Will Forte what I could reveal cuz you
know he's really tight-lipped about
stuff and he told me it's ok to let you
know that in a future episode
Carol will be eating cricket Tara will
eat cricket in a future episode we don't
know why now did you have to eat real
crickets for that scene or did you eat
fake crickets I have any real crickets
and I was eating I'm like take after
take just real cricket it's probably 50
or 60 crickets just get them down cuz
yeah I'll put anything in my mouth for a
laugh and then they turn around it was
time for for forte to eat crickets and
he took one bite and he's like oh do we
have those fake crickets and they're
like oh absolutely well and it was
crickets made out of dates like an agave
like just delicious treat and I was like
oh we had fake ones they never told you
ones they never made you eat 50 real
cricket takeout and they bring out the
ones that are made of caviar and nachos
pretty much oh yeah we have big crickets
if you want and I'm like well I don't
have to eat them anymore
now you right I don't
thank ya you've got to get a better
agent you these you brought some
crickets with you I buy some crickets
because I know you really fighting for
real crickets that Kristin says she
enjoys are they cooked in something what
are they crab I think these have a
little bit of I don't know Hickory or
something right yeah yeah yeah okay I
don't know what that does okay they're
really good and they're
[Applause]
[Music]
you go ahead Andy now that question is
do I want a crunchy part or a meaty part
never seen a guy this picky about which
cricket he eats they're kind of like I
think like a chili lemon flavor the
tough part about the cricket is when
your little antennas and the legs get
stuck in your throat on the way down
that's the tough part well Kristin and
her sister in Orlando are opening a
cricket Hut you can go and you can eat
crickets and it opens tomorrow and
that's a good place each each one is
inspected personally to make sure it's
got its antennas on yeah all right
season 2 of the lot would you think
that's awful
[Applause]
we shouldn't we should have stowed alive
when in there yeah I guess I just pulled
an antenna off my tongue I really did
really like a pube
[Applause]
I feel like I've been a bad guest but no
you're not the problem now
Oh Kristen leave it someone elephant it
we have a guy who just gets cricket
don't worry about it's a union thing Oh
cricket Meister wake up you yeah I'm a
communicator I wanted the people to
understand what I was going all right
this show will never be seen by anyone
yeah we're gonna show a Casper the ghost
[ __ ] hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography